alright I'll go ahead and get started
try to get through this before everybody
kind of slips into the post lunch now so
today we're going to talk about
generating and compiling code at run
time with Rozlyn it's a it's a cool new
feature relatively cool new feature in
net there's a lot of really powerful
things we can do with it
so I want to talk about I'll really just
kind of the journey what it is good for
I have a lot of friends that are in F
sharp or a lot of common people running
around and they're always trying to
convince you you know c-sharp is old its
tired come do this new thing well this
is like a cool thing that c-sharp has
that a lot of other languages don't that
might end up being a big deal for us so
about me just a little bit so I'm Jeremy
Miller been around for a while a few of
you might remember me from code better
calm back in a day but I'm an author of
a couple open source language open
source tools all of which up here I'm
going to talk about I'm gonna bring
examples hopefully some positive
examples there definitely some negative
examples of the tools that are listed
there today we're gonna look at some
really old structure map code I had to
go dig into SourceForge to find an
example that most of you forgot source
board still exists but it's still around
I'm gonna pull something from Martin
which is definitely not an ORM okay so
there's a couple tools in specific I'm
not going to get into the specifics of
the tool so I'm not trying to sell you
on the tool I'm just talking about the
techniques we've used inside of this so
two closely related things lamar and
jasper that are my projects that use
this technique and then we're going to
as an example we're gonna take a look at
reef it and we're gonna build a very
minimalist replacement or welcome a
project using this technique to do what
reef it does but we're certainly not
trying to compete with reef it or do it
for real okay
so all of you may not and your daily
lives may not be necessarily doing
anything dynamic with net but even if
you aren't it's very likely you're using
tools of some kind or another that are
calling your code that are doing dynamic
things that are the curtains and so
you're saying oh I hate some of this
stuff but you're probably using some of
it somewhere so JSON serializers they're
called hitting properties setting
properties on your classes ioc
containers of course are doing all kinds
of reflective things messaging
frameworks it's been an MVC core it's
just part of our daily lives maybe just
maybe you've tried to build something
like this yourself I'm just kind of
likely if you're the kind of developer
that comes to a conference like in DC
London so let's let's jump into some of
those so let's look a little bit at just
a very typical MVC controller so and
we're going to use this in a later demo
so very simple just allows us a couple
endpoints to post a new user object a
new user document which is pretty fancy
and one that'll let us grab it by name
but just looking at the elements here
how does a speed on MVC core go from our
class in our code but what it's really
starting from is a request delegate
everything has to look like a function
of give me an HTP context and then you
just return a task to tell me when
you're done
MVC itself is acting as an intermediary
intermediary between HP context and
calling your code so here we've had to
decorate it a little bit we've got an
attribute to tell it what the route is
this eye action result that we return
this is kind of kind of help in VC core
know what to do after it calls your
method the from body attribute is
telling MVC core hey I need to serialize
deserialize the contents of the request
body into this user type and push it
there's a lot of information here we're
having to give MVC core so the DC core
knows how to use our code runtime
bootstrapping and runtime shame on me I
didn't do the research but to the best
of my knowledge in VC core is building
up funks with expressions and compiling
compiling lambdas to actually do the
running and we'll take a look at that
that's kind of nasty stuff all right so
let's go back to take a little bit of a
history lesson the ways we've done this
in dot in the past or what your options
are so the easiest way to do any kind of
dynamic coding is reflection API it's
still by far the easiest thing to use
it's approachable most of you probably
used it a lot of you have probably been
burned in the past by using reflection
to dig into an internal type or member
and who's done that and then let's see
if the same hands show up how many have
you been burned when the underlying butt
library changed underneath you yeah me
too me too
based on their core has been really
terrible for that but so reflection is
very slow it's very easy the one thing
it has an advantage on where it's still
useful no matter how good this other
stuff looks reflection has the fastest
slows cold start time so if you only
have to do something one time in your
application doing it where the
reflection is still the fastest way to
do it rather than having the overhead of
compiling something new just to use it
once one of the cool things getting into
the a spinet course built in DI
container they're smart enough to know
that that when they're activating is
singleton they'll actually go to pure
reflections of trying to compile a new
lambda just to be using it once so that
cold start times really important as
well
il generation I'm not not sure how many
people remember you can do this but
let's take a look at it because I've got
a sample so this is going back this is
on SourceForge
so I'm pretty sure that this code was
probably written maybe around two
thousand five two thousand maybe 2006
we've learned a few things there so this
is very fast I would call it masochistic
I actually know people that claim to
like doing this but I think it's just
kind of a just kind of a showing off
kind of thing of hahaha I'm so smart I
can code in il but if you look at it
it's a step maybe a couple steps above
going right down to assembly language
you have to deal with stacks it was just
nasty to use the way I pulled this off
I had an il book open the whole time but
what you really did is you wrote the
code you were trying trying to generate
and you go use that old il Dasom code
dump out the il that was generated from
that and you try to program to match it
and that sounds like that should be easy
but it wasn't it was a lot of trial and
error and some of you are laughing so
you definitely tried to do this in her
hurt okay about ten years ago when we
got net three point five we got lambdas
we got expressions we got the ability to
build up some dynamic code by using the
expression API model and then we can
compile that to a strong type func or
action of some sort and that's a lot
better but it's still weird and let me
show you example so this code back here
in any time please if any text on the
screen isn't big enough the guys in the
back will just just wake me up so this
isn't doing very much this is from my
martin project that is trying to make
Postgres act like a document database
for dotnet developers which is most
definitely not an ORM all this code is
doing is creating a func that knows how
to go from a mob
object that has an ID and maybe you're
also storing a few properties in
duplicated fields and going from that to
being able to call the store procedure
that's customized for that document type
and now that I just minted that I have
written a stored procedure in the last
couple years please stay with me please
still respect me but this codes kind of
wonky I mean it is it is expressed in
terms of code the things that you
already know how to do those parameters
there's Method calls there's this block
thing that's just a group of them but
still we've got a great community for
Martin there's a lot of other people
developing on it and taking it all kinds
of ways but this stuff is so specialized
that when weird stuff comes up with it
there's only a very few handful of us
that will go and try to tackle this and
make changes with this it's not a very
approachable model I would guess today
that most of the ioc tools are using
probably most of the ORM and dotnet
today are probably using this technique
anybody using in-service bus I believe
from from version six on okay well I
won't tell the guy that won't tell the
particular guys that many hands went up
they went through a huge effort to stop
trying to create so many objects and to
try to dynamically generate expressions
to have things kind of pre compiled in a
lot faster and they made a huge
advantage for them in terms of how much
they throttled the memory how many
objects had to create and how fast they
were
okay now some other things that adapt
that frameworks do so they can call your
code we're all familiar with adapter
types of some kind messaging frameworks
we usually have some kind of eye handler
of T interface where it implements this
interface and your one argument is
taking in T which is your message type
and maybe some kind of context it's just
a way for you to be able to take your
code and make it caller bol by the
framework and it doesn't have to be that
bad but it still kind of pollutes your
code you get to the point where you're
not really writing code you're writing
code for a framework if you're not
careful and your application code may
not be usable outside the confines of
that framework it's worst possible way
you can go you can also just use lambdas
where you just say thinking of example
Sinatra flavored web applications like
Nancy FX or gal Carter where you say for
this route run this function that takes
a request a response and returns a task
right that's another way to do that the
stack traces some of the downside the
stack traces that came out of it aren't
super helpful that that was a real
problem for me in my structure map
library that's an IOC tool when I first
moved from il to expressions I didn't
pay attention to stock traces at first
so anytime something blew up in
structure map you would get this massive
stack trace with a bunch of junk related
to all these dynamic expressions that
had no bearing to any of you problems
and way deep in the middle of it might
say yeah you had a no reference
exception in a constructor but you had
to wade through a whole lot of mess to
get to what mattered and as it be kind
of a tool vendor or somebody that writes
tools for other people it turns out you
really want your stack traces to be
readable legible and to help people
solve problems very quickly or they're
gonna come to you with those problems
all right
so let's jump into hello world Roslin's
the cool thing
we can actually use the Rosalind
compiler we can actually use it in
memory we can stuff code at it and we
can build an assembly on the fly and
load types out of it so let's just do do
the very basic little world how we do it
in the back all right a good speaker
would have this all sorted out before
they start so I work on a tool called
Lemar and it has a core library and it
called Lemar compiler that is a thin
layer on top of the Rosslyn Rosalind
api's there's a little bit of trickery
going on about creating references to
assemblies and invoking the compiler not
a lot but this is this assembly
generator class here it's a little
helper so what I want to do to make this
easier to call let's say we have an
interface called eye greeter
that just has one method that's just
going to return a string right so we can
call up the hello world I don't have to
use the interface but using the
interface just makes it easier for us to
interact and talk to the dynamically
generated classes so inside of a next
unit test I'm going to fire up this
assembly generator class this is going
to invoke the compiler eventually I need
to tell it just like you would with your
own dotnet projects I have to make
references to the assemblies that export
types they're gonna be part of the
generated generated assembly so my
dynamic assembly here is gonna have to
have it's gonna have to have a reference
to the current assembly because that's
where that I greet our interfaces may be
I'm gonna make this a little more clear
okay now behind the scenes if you do
this completely on your own without
using a little mark compiler here it's
it's recursive so Lamarr compiler here
is smart enough when you say your
reference assembly it's smart enough to
add references to every assembly that
this assembly refers to it's on and so
on and so on so that you can actually
compile so when we say reference
assembly this assembly is an extra unit
library so it's adding references to X
unit and everything actually depends on
all the way down okay
so simple as possible thing I could do
hard coding everything let's just we're
gonna write this hello world class and
real quick off on the fly this method
here is going to generate whatever
assembly right off the bat for whatever
code is written at the bottom of it now
that we have an assembly object if you
ever done any kind of custom type
scanning we can go look for all the
exported public types out of it this one
should only have one to go grab it
create this greeter cast it to our eye
greeter interface and now it could
finally use it and then let's give it a
shot it's just going to run next unit
test and it should spit out hello in DC
London into the test results Yes No
maybe so let's go yep that's running
and there we go
there's a little world let me stop and
say if you're not familiar with the
editor this is JetBrains writer just in
case hotties in the room
thank you to jetbrains for my OSS
license for writer I really appreciate
okay any questions about that before I
move on
okay well it's go see more profound
things though okay
so doing research for this talk the last
couple days I just trying to ask on
Twitter just see who else is using this
thinking that I was ahead of the curve
and this was something that was new and
fancy and now there's actually a lot of
projects that already use this today so
raven DB is using this the refit library
we're going to talk about a little bit
more is using it as well
ym that's a document generator the cake
build engine script C yes well I mean
they were really the first to do wacky
things with Rozlyn like this so this is
becoming more and more common talking to
some of the authors of these tools they
did hit some of the same problems I hit
this Roselyn runtime generation it had a
pretty severe problem with cold start
times originally so that first time you
try to activate the compiler when this
stuff was new a couple years ago it
would take almost a four to five second
hit on a high-end developer machine just
to kind of warm up the compiler before
it made the first compilation it's
significantly better today but still be
aware that you can feel it like when
you're trying to start an application or
if you're trying to run an integration
test against your application you can
still feel a half-second lag or that's
what I feel like when the seg is running
so instead the bigger Jasper framework
we'll get to in a while and I Andy's
told me he does the same thing with
Raven the compilation happens either
lazily or it happens in a background
thread
as the application is bootstrapping so
you don't trying to keep the user from
feeling that initial cold start start
time all right so let's get fancy and
I'm gonna admit this is already
pre-built
we're not writing it from scratch but
let's take a look at this let me explain
a little bit of what refit does as we go
along because it's a cool thing that
probably doesn't get enough attention
okay well it makes you actually start so
let's say going back to the same user
controller we have a very small Web API
project off this side this is going to
be a micro service consumed by other
applications inside of our system so
we've got the two endpoints two
endpoints that we care about the create
a name and one I'm going to use strictly
just to kind of show off here just to
track what our users are so let me try
to establish a baseline here I actually
had this application roaming ahead of
time okay let me see if I can get cocky
and stopped and restarted
okay try this again
okay so right now when I start this
application up the only two users well
just take my word for it the only two
users up here are looking like because
we're using a star wars-themed now so
what refid does this is the API we want
to call so rather than picking up HP
client factory it should be client and
handcrafting the code to do all the json
serialization the json the necessary
JSON headers except headers content
headers whatnot what if instead and what
reef it does for us what you say you can
just create an interface that is what
you want the rest of your application to
talk to so we have methods for the get
user and the create and because it's in
perfect world there's still a little bit
of attribute goop the get and post here
which I stole shamelessly from reef it
just expresses the URL pattern to the
real thing whatever the real services so
what we would like now is to just
declare this i user service and kind of
step into meta programming you know like
all your cool ruby friends can do let's
actually do it with dotnet just knowing
this interface and assuming we can
connect to configuration to pick up the
real URL let's build a class for this on
the fly something that we can use at
runtime
is anybody here using refit for real
okay a few do you like it we didn't use
it on my current project because I'd
honestly forgotten all about it and I
really wish we had okay let's try this
so I'll promise to write a blog post in
the next couple days
for before I head back home that just
kind of walks through the details of how
this was built but I whipped up some
code that feet in feet in the type you
want with you do need a prebuilt ioc
container and this is only gonna work
with lamar but knowing these things it
can generate the concrete class you want
to use so I'm doing here assuming this
works because it did this morning it's
gonna tell us what the source code was
that it tried to generate let's give
that shot real quick it'll come out in
this window when it does okay
so we are we have an implementation of
that I user interface it's only
dependency for right now is an I HP
client factory or a newfangled stuff you
see see I mean this is code this is
generated code it's like generated code
everywhere it's kind of ugly you know if
you see the complete full names
everywhere my theory is if you are
previewing the generated code to try to
understand what's happening you can just
copy paste it into a real code file
reformat it with three sharp or whatever
you use and get it to be clean and
pretty that aside you can see the
concrete steps we need to take which is
probably about what you would do if you
were coding this from hand I need to
build up an HP request message it's
easier not to use the shorthand post
async whatever just so this is flexible
enough to handle any kind of HTTP method
so build up the HP request message deal
with serialization along the way I've
had this push in a couple comments just
to kind of explain where this is coming
from let me go down and see the other
method same kind of thing this is a
proof of concept so I'm not really
trying to make this fast so if you were
building this for real you would have to
do something a little more elaborate
than just JSON convert doc to sterilise
object but just just just go with this
but we're generating from the signature
we're able to generate code that's going
to call the HP proxies okay
we've taken just a tiny bit look at some
of the things are going on here so this
is all exposed in Willmar compiler a
library which is believer not for
anybody who has ever used any of my
tools over the years believe it or not
this is actually documented
I'm not gonna go too far into the model
model and what it does but let's look at
it a little bit of it okay
so Mar compiler or is really trying to
do is to be able to build just really
complicated methods that did some kind
of unit of work handling an HP request
in a web framework handling a message
inside of a service bus are now using it
here as kind of a string of operations
to make an HTTP call through HP client
and interpret the results so the
building blocks inside the lamar
compiler model the idea of a frame which
was really loosely a logical operation
in the code the most common ones you're
going to use would be just either
calling a method or calling a
constructor and everything else is kind
of weird the frames in depth kind of
being built in a chain model a linked
list and probably more than you want to
know right now but just so you have the
ability if necessary to wrap code around
something else like have a try-catch
block that wraps anything that comes on
and inside of it so by building this
model and how it is adapted a little bit
they said I will try to promise to have
a blog post that's more explanatory
about this but generating the the
methods on-the-fly for this interface
it's code like this where we're
interrogating the signature a little bit
and then we just add the right frames to
the method and compilation time this
thing is smart enough to know what
little bits dad's of code actually gets
written in okay I think that is enough
on that model but just for fun what's
actually run the whole thing
okay so test right here that I'm about
to run set up a little bit of a
container so this is the Lamar container
that is the spiritual successor of two
structure map because I don't want to
support structure map anymore and I
wanted people to have a way off of it so
it's very specific the only things that
really matter here using the same @hp
client the same bootstrapping that you
would use in an MVC core application
today just to add that to the service
registrations because lamar supports the
asp.net cuore di model out of the box
and then there's a policy here that's
specific to Lamar it just says if you
ask for a service that I don't know
about today and that service has beat
this and if that service hat is marked
has methods that are marked with these
refet clone attributes I'm going to go
ahead and make up a class on the fly
that implements this interface that does
what I think you want it to do so you're
probably saying this is too much magic I
don't like it and that's all fair but
this is enough right here to set up the
application container so now I should be
able to say go grab a user not knowing
that it's being built on the fly and
this is a dynamic class but go do it and
we do a sanity check to make sure it's
not null and we're gonna go post a new
user called Darth Vader and we'll have a
little family reunion so I'm just going
to call the methods and then we go try
to fetch our fader to prove that he's
really there know before we do that
let's do the you know nothing up your
sleeve kind of thing so I call this
method refresh just to see what's here
so right now the only two users up there
Luke and Leia and then let's run our
tests
during this whole thing
and while that's running uh so my
younger son is gonna turn five in about
a week or so and I had to deal with his
older brother years ago that he wasn't
allowed to watch Star Wars the movie
until he turned five so we made it this
huge deal with my younger son of you get
to watch Star Wars when he turned five
so that's what I get to do on the
weekend when I'm home from in DC make
sure it's actually running okay we're
running in okay so everybody see now we
have Darth Vader or you can go use the
existing refit library that does this
and much much more
but alright actually something that does
bother me so there there are so many
children's books now out there with Star
Wars
you know like start fading and sullen
and Darth Vader and his and his daughter
they're the really cute little books but
my five-year-old soon-to-be
five-year-old was read all these books
for years and he's not gonna have that
that just this aural shock during Empire
Strikes Back of oh my god Darth Vader is
Luke's father and I just kind of feel
sorry for him no come
so any questions about the what we just
saw before I move on cuz I'm gonna grab
a drink real quick so mark I was when I
grew up so I lived in a farm pretty far
out of town and it was hard to go in and
see movies so all of my cousins who
lived in town got to see Return of the
Jedi just like two months before me and
spent that two months trying to tell me
that no Yoda says it's true and I've
just tried to fight with him the whole
time no it's a lie so I was the last
child in America that year to know the
truth so right there I think you all
know exactly how old I am then okay so
let's talk about frameworks because the
main usage for all this technique is
really writing frameworks some of you're
saying well I really want to piece
together libraries I should be
delivering value for my client I
shouldn't be writing frameworks but once
in a while it's going to be justified so
let's just pretend that they're not
always terrible things and just just go
with it a little bit excuse me
engine sounds like a great one I don't
know every time I've done a rolls engine
it's always been event condition action
so there's always I event I condition I
action and yeah I suppose so
that's definitely something I'd want to
take off the shelf so have you build the
rules okay I mean it's pretty common to
build build a world Limited rules engine
that's very specific to your problem
domain and I'm not looking down on
anyone for that but it's also a great
way to waste a lot of your employer's
time okay so frameworks that they're
very best when it when they're good for
you when when they're helpful they allow
you to develop a lot faster but just
taking care of repetitive work like
we're dealing with MVC core you're not
seeing
they're manually grabbing the HP
contacts the invoke a JSON serializer to
go read stuff all the time
I mean you do once in a while for
special things but the happy path of
JSON and JSON out
it's just dealing with that for you so
you don't have to worry about it right
that's a good thing
dealing with object life cycles and
disposal
like most frameworks today whether it's
a messaging framework or an HP framework
something where you're issuing commands
it's taken care of things like
activating the unit work disposing it
when you're done
all those things that if you did not
take care of them would leave to a
massive memory leak in your application
but if you're staying within the narrow
the well-lit paths you just let the
framework handle that for you so there's
less stuff for you to worry about a good
framework and a good application
framework should be able to handle a lot
of cross-cutting concerns like can you
just throw some generic I want to get
rid of work transactional boundary just
do it for me or I want to wrap security
around it some kind of middleware that
that's helpful to take repetitive tasks
away and then as much as possible and
this is this is my opinion and a lot of
people don't agree with this I want the
framework to get out of my way
completely I don't want to see a lot of
cruft in my code I don't want to see a
lot of marker interfaces a lot of
attributes that's all garbage and junk
other people will have the attitude of I
like that because it's explicit and I
know a little bit more about what's
going on there's room in the world for
both of us I just wish there was more
room for me frameworks at their very
worst they're gonna force you to use a
lot of adapter classes so you're not
doing something that validates your
writing a behavior behavior or a
middleware that then calls the thing you
wanted to call and eventually that kind
of weight can wear you down a lot of
extra actually this is a dinette problem
except the Java guys have caught up to
me attributes in your code
you know especially looking at some
older Microsoft frameworks and I'm
thinking WCF or or really anything that
came out of Microsoft in the mid-2000s
post Longhorn phase where it was just so
many attributes to do so very little bit
of code problem I incurred and I'm gonna
show the negative example way too many
object allocations by having all these
adapter classes that then just called
normal code you're creating a lot more
objects than you would would if you were
writing everything from scratch bespoke
that could be a problem under heavy
loads you're making the garbage
collector work way harder and you can
actually see performance problems
because of the GC
kicking in to clean things up or just
blasting through memory and I of course
know this because I caused this problem
at my prior previous employer ok poor
performance just saying it's closely
related all the bad too many objects too
many layers of indirection to build this
object that just calls that that calls
that and you see where that goes and
then the absolutely just epic stack
traces I'm going to talk a little bit
more about this
I've heard this attributed attributed to
a lot of different people but you've
heard the joke that Enterprise Java is a
DSL to turn huge piles of XML into
massive stack traces except I'm not
innocent okay for any Generation X
people out there my college roommate was
huge in the cake and it took me 20 years
to like them again but so with this
cogeneration stuff and theory here is we
can have all the good stuff we want we
can keep our code really clean but we
can still be fast
even if we're using this really flexible
middleware generation if we could just
generate the the kind of goop adapter
code instead of creating a bunch of ton
of classes or introducing a little bit
of conventions where we can look at your
code and we know how it's one to be
called when we looked at the I user
service it's good I can take down a peak
adapt okay we look at I user service we
can look at the code the signature of
the code and that tells us a lot about
the intention of what this should really
do just generate code for it so this is
a lot funnier in my head when I was
telling people about this a month ago
but I still love that song so okay so
years and years ago
I blew an extraordinary amount of energy
time and emotional attachment to a
project called fabu MVC that was an
alternative web framework in about the
Oh a toe 9 2010 timeframe that's the
highlight of in DC London for me so far
one of the volunteers came up to me and
said they used it and they actually
liked it and he would still talk to me
but it's mostly forgotten for good
reason
so we did flew BC our big thing was
trying to make this thing as flexible as
possible so we loved the very early idea
of that every framework uses now of the
Russian doll model of if you look at NBC
core or asp.net apiece asp.net core by
itself middleware you have an outer
middle middleware that sits on the
outside maybe that's handling security
maybe it's handling exception what
request comes in it's able to surround
everything but call into maybe a
validation middleware in between which
eventually gets to your guy inside so
you think about those Russian stacking
dolls and every time I do this talk
there is actually a native Russian
speaker who tells us how to pronounce it
right but I can't do it so I won't try
but that was the motif we used to
describe what we wanted to look like so
that is why the sp2 neck
where is today all right it's great it
makes a lot for us to do things like I'm
going to completely ignore security for
now and at the end I'm gonna slap
identity server middleware around
everything and boom
I have authentication without having to
worry about it for the past three months
ideally okay so FUBU DC did it with this
idea called behaviors it's just this is
before everybody just adopted the term
middleware and went with it so
middleware behavior and FUBU BC was very
closely analogous to SP done in core
middleware implementation wise is
probably closer to an action filter from
from the VC just kind of go with it so
that this code here was a transactional
behavior if you're using martin the
martin application or the martin library
to do persistence in your application
inside of a filling vc application that
this behavior just allowed you to do
just the transaction boundary around
this so by wrapping this and whatever
other behaviors are inside of it down to
the actual controller action maybe some
other things so that everything that was
done inside of this would be in the same
unit of work in the same logical
database transaction okay kind of cool
but what happened when this was taken
way too far where we had a transaction
behavior around everything and there's
validation stuff and there's update a
log writer route to the record of hey i
was here in a couple different actions
you get to the point where there was
literally about 20 different behaviors
all nested inside of each other you know
one it was really slow because every
time you executed a request this is all
build up from a container of this on the
outside something on the inside inside
inside so you're creating a ton of
objects you're making your ioc container
work really hard and win this blew up
when it blew up in your side of your
controller actions all that gunk on the
outside got into the stack trace and it
was epic it was I have no business
making fun of Java Enterprise Java
developers for their stack traces
because this this was just terrible so
flash forward and let me see if I can
make some amends to the rest of the
world here okay so the Jasper framework
which is still heavily in flight may
never get out of in-flight but it's at
least proving out I think this this
technique and maybe it's something
somebody else could you look at and go
write their own better thing but looking
at the past of fubu BC as as the failure
its alloys a lot of I'm fighting the
last war what are we gonna do
differently this time well one want to
be a lot faster this time I want this
thing to really perform and scream part
of the way it's gonna be faster this is
a big trend I've seen all over the
dotnet world is this new obsession that
probably a little bit healthy of
minimizing the memory allocations that
happen at runtime the guys working on
are excuse me the folks working on
Kestrel there's an amazing work you've
all seen dinette Corps places like forth
right now in the tech and power
performance shootout and then knowing
that the three things above it are just
barely faster and they're all
experimental things a speeding a core is
the fastest HTTP handling thing on the
planet that's actually meant to be
productive and used in production apps -
Joel know that so it's been cool and but
they've done it by relentlessly reducing
memory allocations so I want to try to
copy that kind of kind of go on the same
thing I still like the idea of trying to
keep the code that users write just as
clean as possible
nope no marker interfaces minimal
attributes nope no goop that does mean
that you're using some naming
conventions which some people hate let's
come down the next side that let's have
some way that's really easy for users to
see what is jest we're trying to do with
my code what is it surrounding around it
so they have a way to kind of unravel
what the behavior is and my theory is by
using generated c-sharp to apply all
your middleware and your transactional
boundaries and all that good stuff just
show the user this is the generated code
with the hope that anybody using this
tool already understands c-sharp so they
can just look at the generated code okay
when we switch to Jasper itself now
finally so when an HP request is handled
in Jasper every unique route compiled up
front there's going to be a route
handler object for each individual route
and there's really only one method we
care about here very close to a request
delegate this segments thing is passed
in just so it doesn't have to duplicate
the work that the router already did to
split the URL string take in the asp.net
core it should be context return a task
and do whatever you do
so very similar to the control user
controller we talked about it first I'm
gonna build an equivalent in Jasper so
say we have a command that is create
user when this is posted up to our web
service I want you to go make a new user
object and persist it somewhere okay and
because I'm because I like Barton and we
already support Martin for this I'm
gonna assume that my backing persistent
store is Martin which behind-the-scenes
eventually it's just just Postgres this
is the Jasper endpoint to handle the two
HP endpoints here one to go get a user
by its ID there's a little bit of a
naming convention this is enough to get
out the path slash user slash and ID is
a route argument we'll just notice a few
things here all the methods are static
they don't have to be they can be
instance methods they can be async that
it can not be anything but in this case
I'm just chewing any kind of constructor
injection just like in VC core and I did
get the idea from them we're just gonna
let you inject services directly as as
arguments here makes your code a little
bit simpler your code just becomes
functions and classes and methods right
up here same thing we're taking that
command Jess we're just gonna assume the
first argument here that's a that's not
a route argument we just assume that's
the message body so you don't have to do
the from body attribute take into things
you need that's the Martin I document
session and I logger you probably use
today I said try to minimize the usage
of attributes but it's an imperfect
world
so easiest possible way to say I want
the Martin transactional middleware
applied to just that one single method
is just marking with an attribute okay
so this is actually completely
functional which we're not going to try
to disprove by
actually running it but let's let's look
at the generated code for this okay I
have this let's see so one of the things
with Jasper we've embraced the command
line which III love the dotnet CLI I
think it's been a great model it's been
a great advance I am perfectly cool with
dotnet stealing good stuff from nodejs
but one of the things Jasper does is it
adds a couple new commands to its
command line support for strictly for
Diagnostics the net run will run your
application just like you're used to but
there's a few other helpful things so
this code command will have it start up
the application a lightweight start up
so it doesn't start up the the server
the kestrel server or run any kind of
background services but do that and then
show me what all the generated code for
all the route handlers or message
handlers so we're just gonna take a leak
look at this and this is going to show
us a quick preview of what the generated
code is when we try to relate this a
little bit so this is a generated code
to get the user by its ID so I mean
we're gonna go back and forth just a
little bit
so this method right here get user
underscore ID so writing the
intermediate code to go from I have an
HP context and I want you to do the rest
of it eventually call this method on the
inside that's this code right here
so what got generated around it starting
up the query session so knowing you have
a Martin document store if you use Raven
DB this should look pretty familiar so
the document store would be analogous to
Raven dbe's document store not
coincidentally or if you from in
hibernate this would be like the I
session factory there's not really an
equivalent and EF core then this the
query session here this would be
analogous to a dbcontext in e of core
this one the query session super
lightweight it only does read-only
exposes read things but it does need to
be cleaned up and disposed at the end
and make sure you're cleaning up any
database connections to post graphs so
we definitely need to do it here it's
doing it generating with using statement
to make sure it gets cleaned up inside
of that chattering a little bit of code
it is generating code to be able to grab
the route argument from the route and
this is just a string so it doesn't have
to do anything but grab the segments the
segment's array the ID we know is on
slot number one of that array and then
we execute our endpoint and because this
is a static we didn't have to create any
new objects but we could have we passed
in the service and then down here this
is Jasper stuff this is just writing
writing the JSON back out to the
response looking a little more
interesting model so the right
here let's get let's get a little bit
cocky about this so when we write get it
to the point because we're using the
transactional middleware up there I
don't have to worry about committing the
session the middleware is gonna do it
for me
so something else could combine into the
unit of work so I can get to the point
where I can write code like this where
take in to create user command and what
I'm trying to achieve is to create a new
user document persist it and I'll log it
just to show more stuff going on just to
store it to the session that's a
synchronous method so I don't need to
worry about any kind of tasks and that's
why I get away with a void up here
because I don't care so I don't have to
be returning a lot of tasks completed
tasks to make the compiler shut up I can
write the easiest code to do what I want
it to do let's take one quick peek more
peek at this nice make sure to save it
and then I'm gonna flip over to the
command line and regenerate it because I
changed the code okay this one just a
tiny bit fancier so when it generates
this class from the container the Lemar
containers still hanging around in there
but from the configuration of the Lemar
container I know that I documents store
is a singleton I know that the ilogger
of whatever is a single thing and it's
important here so this request handler
this is only created it actually
instantiated once in the entire
application and stuffed in the right
place and the routing tree so by knowing
that these are Singleton's I can just
inject these in one time and these are
completely in line for every other
subsequent HTTP call if you're using
really just about any other done yet
that
tool like this it's making an IOC
resolution of your controller every
single time and most of the good ioc
containers are are good about inlining
Singleton's and they're generated funks
but they may not be but what could
easily be happening to you is there's a
bunch of dictionary looks at lookups
inside the ioc container to find the
right strategy of how to build it and
execute it there's just a lot of stuff
going on that happens every time at
runtime what we're trying to do with
jasper we're trying to eliminate that as
much as possible by knowing about the
ioc configuration upfront knowing about
what all the right life cycles are some
rules about code generation we're trying
to bake that kind of decision making
this run time and a lot of other
frameworks trying to do that upfront and
compile it one time so that that's why
we take in the document store at a
logger one time when this is created
inside of this the session has to be
scoped to the request and it knows that
so everybody that would want or to use a
document session will get this the frame
model is smart enough that it can write
the inner stuff and in between so
there's a frame that knows how you need
an ID document session I can do that for
you I'm gonna create this but from the
document store directly wrap everything
around using so it all gets saved this
is just reading the JSON request
actually calling your endpoint method
and this is all this is all voids
there's no work no async no wait but
down below it knows this document
session and Save Changes they sync is
definitely a sync I'm gonna do that
another side benefit of this code
generation model is assuming we do this
stuff well it should embed and encode
the right keys a wait here a sink
do you actually try to if the last call
returns a task and it's the only thing
that's async we just return the tasks so
you don't have to use
the inefficient async keyword but let
the framework smarts and the
cogeneration smarts handle more of that
low-level handling so you can worry
about strictly worried a little bit more
about what your applications really
doing which is not a whole lot and then
years ago mark Rendell over there in the
middle trying to stay awake watch the
talk of his and talked about how he
tried to be pretty strict with HTTP
status codes okay so I did listen to one
of your talks and after an hour of
listening to mark talked with that
Liverpool accident I went home and I
listen to The Beatles for the next day
straight you are from Liverpool sure
okay you sound like Paul McCartney to me
stupid Ugly American okay so you all
know that so you know I'll know that
they have done there's there some
linguistic studies that I have a
Midwestern American accent so I'm
neutral everybody else has an accident
but people in the northeast of the u.s.
they have been able to prove that that's
what English people sounded like in the
1700 1600s whenever and y'all drifted
off a different way and they stayed
behind
okay so I resent that a little bit
representative so my one the one English
ancestor I know about my grandmother's
grandfather always bragged that he had a
fortune back in England if he could just
get back to get it so I may or may not
probably not and from some kind of
English aristocracy that aside so that
aside to be a little more correct with
with HP status codes because this is
creating let's override and force the
status code to to a 1 which means
created
don't anybody correct me if that's wrong
and let me see how the code generation
changes real simple in visa core does
the same thing I know I've seen this in
Nancy in the past if you're returning an
integer we assume that means to be the
status code so if we look now there's
just a little bit of code to take the
result of that end point method and then
just immediately write it to the status
code okay any questions about that and I
swear I'm about to wrap up okay so
conclusions here what I think and hope
is being able to do this kind of dynamic
runtime generation with c-sharp code or
it does support vbe if people still do
that that this is much more approachable
to many more people that you could do
more elaborate things or just the
barrier entry to getting into this is
much lower because we all know c-sharp
so I'm gonna claim it's not that scary
the if you look at the code generation
code it looks kind of messy some of that
is just being able having to order who's
dependent upon what the string
interpolation having that in c-sharp was
that seven or did that come in six okay
that that that's a lifesaver I don't
know if you would even want to try to do
this without string interpolation but
that makes a big deal but the models
just not that bad
so I'm also hoping this kind of gives us
a big potential to start making the
frameworks we use from here on out be a
lot faster maybe some more intention
revealing code maybe this is something
you could actually incorporate when you
need small dynamic frameworks in your
own application and with that I'm done
[Applause]